let's deal with solipsism actually
before i go to solipsism i want to talk
about
jealousy as it relates to um
humans promiscuity because
a lot of people men included like a lot
of white knights will do this too
but a lot of people will paint
uh you know society with the same brush
oh if men do it women can do it too you
know you hear these women like
well these guys are gonna you know go
and bang other girls and i should be
able to do it too it's like
i'm going to have a notch count if
they're going to have a notch count well
it's like
if you want to but the reality is
if you got a high notch count as a check
then you make an incredibly poor choice
for a high value guy for top shelf man
to choose you for trophy wife material
okay they just don't choose women like
that typically unless they're totally
blue pilled and blind to the reality of
the world
women and men do not operate by the same
rule book
if you haven't noticed stand in front of
a mirror
naked beside your woman or any chick
and take a look at the build of your
bodies and you'll recognize men and
women are in fact
very different our sexual strategies are
in fact different they're not the same
and women and men can't do the same
things
right i mean the difference is you could
list them for miles
men have more upper body strength like
two-thirds more upper body strength than
women women's leg strength is
closer you know to men's but it's still
not even the same as
on par as men's there's a lot of
differences between
i mean the obvious women can have babies
men can't
despite what you know the social night
you know narrative is saying with
i don't know all these ads now like oh
you know men can menstruate too
really okay anyway we're gonna stay away
from those topics but
men and women get jealous for um
different
reason men get jealous because
of they because they fear paternity
men are more concerned with what she's
doing
on an intimate level they're not that
concerned if she's talking to kevin from
sales
she's porking kevin from sales that's
something he's going to have a problem
with
women on the other hand have more of a
problem if you're talking to
i don't know what's the chicks version
cindy
sheila whatever you know if you're
talking to sheila from the hr department
okay if you're you know if you're
porking her too that's of course going
to be a problem but she has a lot more
concern
with anything that might escalate into
intimacy men have a lot more concern
with any kind of intimacy itself the
conversation piece
not a big deal and the reason for that
is because women when they're pregnant
have 100 percent assurance
of paternity they know the child is
theirs
men on the other hand as a function of
evolution and because women cuck men
constantly throughout history
and if you're not familiar with cuck or
cuckoldry all that means is
she's taken on the seed of another man
but convinces
the schlep that it's his kid so she
takes on
usually the premier genetic investment
of a better uh
male like an alpha male and then finds
some beta
to pay the bills and raise this dude's
kid so that's what cuckoldry is
but men on the other hand again they get
jealous because they don't have 100
assurance of paternity so they want to
make sure that their woman is sexually
exclusive to them if they're going to
invest in them
women on the other hand are more
concerned with provisioning
resources and protection they're not so
concerned
with where he's parking his wiener
right and that's part of the reason why
you'll hear throughout the trp community
um women are okay to share a high value
alpha
they'd rather do that in fact than be
straddled with a faithful loser
it's why you see women choose to date
and go out with married men like they
would rather date a guy
that lives with their wife than a guy
that lives in their mom's basement
that's just how women are right high
value guy
he's already been made selected by
somebody else or social proof
she'll go out with the married guy
before she goes out with a guy living in
his mom's basement of the same age
making no money
that's just how women behave so you have
to understand these
innate behaviors when it comes to
loyalty because when i see guys that are
like
well i want big boobs and a bum and she
has to be loyal it's like
you don't you're you're you're starting
off from the wrong
point here okay you have to understand
female nature
and and and stop ext you know expecting
women to be loyal forever and ever until
kingdom come because they're only as
loyal as their options
right and you'll hear a lot of the guys
in you know more of the mgtow
communities talk about that
and i agree with everything that they
observe
my solution to the problem is often
different than that
so just get your head around is what i'm
saying here
now the last thing that drives our
choices what are we at we're almost at
the
30 minute mark um let me grab the link
so you guys can start piling in to ask
questions because that sometimes takes a
little bit i know some of you
uh come in a little late so ask
a question so make sure you got
headphones
wired headphones or something so the
audio is good and a decent connection
and when you come in um
there's a private chat let me know what
your question is in the private chat so
i can sort through that and
um get to the uh ones more relevant to
you know to the topic or
ones that i think that might be
interesting to talk about anyway um
here's a link
the new female voice is solid thanks
steve
you like that voice
um all right so solipsism
solipsism is straightforward here let me
get the uh definition here for let's get
her get her clean
solipsism find a
dictionary term but i'll expand on a
little bit more
is the uh philosophical sorry
physiological idea that only
one's mind is sure to exist there is a
better definition that what is a
solipsistic person a solipsistic person
is a person that only believes their
mind or
self is sure to exist individuals
experiencing solipsism syndrome feel
reality is not real in the sense of
being internal for their whole mind
the syndrome is characterized by
feelings of loneliness attachment and
difference to the outside world
doesn't define it as it relates to women
the thing that you understand
see it really just boils down to this
when it comes to solipsism in women
all that means is they can't see past
their own nose which is why you hear me
say things like women don't care about a
man's struggle they hang out at the
finish line and they pick the winner
right that's a solipsistic behavior they
don't care
if you had a prick of a boss who treated
you like
dog poo poo and um you quit your job
because he was
a insufferable bastard right they don't
care because they're solipsistic
they'll hang out at the finish line and
they'll pick somebody else because
hypergamy
that's just the way that it is you know
hypergamy doesn't care women are
solipsistic they can't see pastor owners
they don't see
anybody else's problems but their own
it's you know it's one of the reasons
why you don't see women take a lot of
ownership
when it comes to uh faults in
relationships and breakups and that sort
of stuff
they just don't um you know it's very
rare that you hear women say something
like i'm sorry
and mean it
all right some of you guys are piling in
make sure you uh drop in the private
chat what it is your questions about or
what you want to ask me
just helps me sort through a little bit
better so that's solipsism
all right it's you know it's why you're
here not yours it's just your turn
new subscriber and bringing on your
content thanks appreciate the super chat
brother
um yeah that's why you hear it you know
she's not yours it's just your turn
it's it's another sound bite that ties
into hypergamy
befaldslaw and solipsism so what does
all of that mean like how
like how is it that you know you know
this
one or two uh like people or these one
or two couples out there
that have been married for 20 years and
they're very happy with each other and
they're all shmoochie pootsie and all
over them
you know all over each other when you
see them well it's usually because the
guy
managed to continue to chase excellence
throughout his entire life
and she felt like her hypergamy was
satisfied that's
really what it boils down to you know
for the most part i could go through
like a social media platform like
facebook you know for example
and take a look at all my friends and i
can think of
i can think of one right now that has
had a
almost 30-year marriage and he's still
happy with his wife
but he cheated on his wife
she was a pain in the ass a number of
times but they're still all over each
other today
she looked the other way when he cheated
on her right again women are okay to
share a high value
alpha they'd rather do that than be
saddled with a faithful loser
this guy was a champ he still is a champ
chase's excellence
puts a dent in the universe has made
huge bank
um has like literally put a dent in the
universe has has
done things to impact the world uh in
ways that
um many of you out there have probably
been touched by especially if you live
in the west
i'm not going to get into who he is and
what his business is but you get the
idea
um these are the types of long-term
loyal
relationships you know where women don't
leave the guy so when you hear you know
can a woman be loyal yes and no you know
you just have to understand that all of
these things that i'm talking about when
it comes to
hypergamy solidism you know false law
now that you understand it now that you
realize
what it is that drives women to mate
switch
mate switching is actually something we
can spend a minute or two on too um
i have a video on my channel i think i
have this study here still
but um there's a mate switching study
which do i have it in here sexual
economics
mommy's little secret mommy's little
secret's an interesting one if you
if you search for mommy's little secret
on google
um you'll get some idea of why um
women why are you cheating on tinder
that's not it
um why women cuck guys and
how they get away with it i don't have
it here but there's a mate switching
study i did a video on my channel at
some point so if you search on my
channel entrepreneurs and cars plus mate
switching
women will start to indicate
mate switching behaviors long before
they leave in fact
fifty percent of women surveyed so this
is an admission of guilt
when you survey women they don't want to
look bad right but
this is an admission of guilt when
they're going to basically say yeah i
have a backup plan
so you're relying on them being honest
so some women are going to be honest
some women
are going to be dishonest they're going
to say no i don't have a backup plan
even though they do
but the mate switching study clearly
indicates on a balance of probabilities
more women than not have a backup plan
guy
lined up they always have throughout
history
and if they didn't because i mean you go
back 200 000 years a million years ago
if she wasn't self-interested if she
wasn't solipsistic if she wasn't
hypergamous
her and her children probably would not
survive we live in an environment today
where we have the state
which takes care of irresponsible
mothers
uh that will get knocked up multiple
times by different guys and have you
know four children in tow from four
different dudes
doesn't matter that the government will
take care of housing will take care of
basic needs
they don't need no man anymore right but
you go back a million years
uh it was a death sentence if they were
not hypergamous solipsistic you know
so just understand these things right
they're not good or bad they just are
it's like how are you going to respond
to them now now that you know that women
aren't particularly loyal or good at
loyalty and there's
a vast amount of work that you have to
do to keep her
in your frame and loyal to you right
signs that she's not loyal you know
there's all kinds
she's working late more she's having
more girls night outs
she's maybe traveling out of town uh
those seem to be the common ones that
pop up more often not whenever i talk to
guys on one-on-one coaching
sessions when their marriage falls apart
or they found out that she's banging
you know kevin from sales you know for
example those are the things that start
to pop up also
one of the other things that you'll
start to notice as a guy is if she's
still staying
fit and beautiful taking care of herself
she's going to yoga classes or whatever
and you're not having any kind of sexual
intimacy with her whatsoever or it's on
a very limited basis
that's another good sign that the clock
is ticking down to the end of things
and these and there's any number of
things that can go around that but i
wanted to hit this again more from about
25 000 feet of altitude
you